sperm will be some discuss you a lot we
discussed these systemic checks on our
borders this is one of the areas where
we don't fully agree yet with the
European Parliament but it is really of
essence to make sure that security comes
first without systemic controls we
cannot speak about improving the
situation in Europe and there are many
airports where these systemic checks are
already in place you might have
encountered them at airports outside of
the EU for example and I believe that
this should not influence or impair the
fluidity of flows of tourists for
example to any to the EU and outside of
the EU today we have not only discussed
about the measures to address the
immediate needs but also how to build a
more resilient European migration and
asylum policy in order to face
successfully future challenges progress
has been reached on the reform of Euro
deck and to create a new European Asylum
agency they hope we can reach an
agreement by the end of this year
following the official launch as Robert
mentioned before of the European border
and coast guard last week we discussed
the next steps to fully operationalize
the new agency within the coming months
for this I called on the member states
to be fully engaged to set up for
instance the pool of experts however
better managing our external borders in
order to reduce irregular
means also that we have to enhance
pathways for people in need of
protection to come lick at the euro